- I have a big idea.
- Well, what are you going to do man?
You get to, you can figure out
how to pull yourself up without that...
(upbeat music)
10:44 Eastern Time, Friday, September
what's today, the 9th?
- What day is it Mike? Ha ha ha ha ha
- 8th, Friday, September
8. Gary's on a board call
at 9:44. It was not on the calendar.
The request came in, gotta
move a couple things.
(whistle)
Zee, making moves on her end.
- Happy Friday, everyone. Welcome.
- Now he's on the board call.
What's up?
(bell)
- I want to make sure I'm understanding
what you're saying here.
You're super pumped about the
thought process and strategies
behind post production of
the DailyVee vlog on YouTube
because you love the YouTube ecosystem.
[voice on speaker phone]
- Yeah, and I'm finding
we have this chance to do
something big right now.
How are you feeling about
the up from yesterday?
- I'm feeling great, but I'm also
a little bit more patient
than everybody, right,
like if today's is not good,
I'm feeling great about that too, right.
It'll also give us context.
We'll read the qualitative
feedback from the audience.
A lot of them are still
going to say it's great
because they just like me.
- I'm from the DailyVee today.
We are changing our style
so usually we just
document Gary's whole life;
we make a narrative out of that,
but we're trying to go to
more the creative route.
We're so used to recording everything
and we're really trying
to push against that,
kind of balance when to
film, when not to to film.
(hip hop music playing)
[offscreen voice]- Right
now Gary is in a meeting.
It's 11:45. #AskGaryVee isn't set up yet.
- Hi everybody. I'm Gary Vee,
and this is the #AskGaryVee show.
So 268. Wow. It feels
good to be back. Huh?
What a layover. (studio laughing)
Ross, thank you so much for coming today.
Boy, man, I love your shit.
- 12:04, we managed to set it up.
Squad, we roll deep.
[offscreen voice] - Will you sit down?
- Yeah, I'm sorry. (laughter)
Yeah, I'll sit down.
- You know the word we get
them both dropping here?
You got to drop fire?
I got to drop feather.
- Done.
[Offscreen voice] -Okay?
- Fire, feather.
[Offscreen Voice] -I got
feather, you got fire.
- Done. (bell)
Everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
Episode 264 of the #AskGaryVee Show
[offscreen viewer speaking]-
I've developed product
that's coming up on a
year now that transforms
cremated remains into a glaze
for ceramic design objects.
- Tony, admit right now,
this is the greatest show
that you've ever been on. (laughter)
This guy took dead people
turning into glaze.
- This is kind of a new one for me.
- I've got a big idea.
- What are you going to do man?
You get to, you can figure out how
to pull yourself up without
that collapsing. I would...
♫ There's always gonna
be another mountain,
♫ I'm always gonna (music
cut off by signal beep)
(offscreen) - Let go.
- Okay; you know me so well!
I was really going to try!
[Offscreen voice] -Don't
do this! (laughter)
- How's it going?
- It's good,
- Are you doing some of the new stuff? Or?
- Yeah. It's still finding that
cadence that will work out.
- Sure, take's time.
- I didn't realize
that we weren't editing
DailyVee yesterday.
I'm in charge of everybody though.
I could have made somebody not busy.
I could have decided...
I just need to know--
and I know you were sick,
so it was a perfect storm.
The fact that we're back
and episode two is not...
That's crazy.
(hip hop music)
- Yeah? Thank you so much. I
appreciate talking with you.
- Sorry.
- No! Not at all.
(hip hop music)
- Some crazy labs. I was like,
you got to see Gary, right?
Just give this to him!
- Dude, you have two
different colored eyes?
- Yeah.
- How the fuck did I
not notice that before?
Thank you, man.
- He just rolled up on you like...
- He was just waiting outside.
Then after he gave it to me
he runs up and says rrrrr! (laughter)
- Hey everybody. This is
Gary Vaynerchuk. Episode 265
of the #AskGaryVee Show
and the amount of music I have consumed
from the man who is sitting
across from me right now
should be illegal.
When I was 18, John, this
is what I would play.
I'm like, okay, I'm 18. And in
18 years I'm going to be 36.
That's young as shit. I have
my whole life in front of me.
Everything I've just lived,
I have all that time in front of me
and I'm still going to be 36.
Now I'm 41, and I'm like, okay,
I've lived this whole life,
okay in 41 I'm going to be 82.
Hmmmm, 82 is a little like...
Even with the game that
I've played my whole life
about doubling up my number
to make me realize how
much time I still had
so fucking be patient, do the right thing,
shortcuts kill you, like
do it right. I still do it.
Hey.
- Amazing, Brother.
- See you soon.
- That was fucking amazing.
- Take care of yourself. Yeah man.
- Thank you
- It's really good to see you.
I'm really rooting for you.
- Thanks, Bro.
- Yeah, man. Take care.
That was a lot of fun, good
episode. Give it to me.
Culture, attention.
There's so many things
going on in the world
that are winning, but when
you can combine your interest
with what's winning, you
attack it, and for me, hip hop
is an interest of mine,
and then I attack the people that I know.
I know Russ is going to be
one of the biggest artists
in the world in three or four years
and we start establishing a
relationship, paying forward,
I'm putting him on to get
as much for him as possible.
You build a real relationship;
you're not doing it to
expect something in return.
You do the right things,
the right things happen.
- What's up?
- What up, my man?
- Hello, gosh, just getting it, you know.
- I get it.
How's it going?
- We haven't stopped. We haven't stopped.
- I love it. It's going well?
- Things are going great, yeah. Yeah man,
it's exciting day; album's out. And now
what songs are people
relating to, talking about,
busting out, so--just
kind of sitting back,
taking that all in.
- And just consuming, consuming
all the content and feedback
on social?
- That's it.
- Listen. Listen, I really
enjoyed our time together
the other day.
- Yeah, same here. Thank you
so much for inviting me in
and um gosh, having the
#AskGaryVee Show, you kidding me?
- Make's me happy, man.
- We're just rocking
right along, and you know
it's all about awareness right now for us.
- Of course.
- As crowded as the
airwaves are, as you know,
it's all about making sure
as many people as we can
know that we have a new product out there.
That's the battle.
All right, brother, thank
you for all the support.
- Take care.
- Talk to you soon.
- Good bye.
Heading home, going into the weekend.
Going garage sale-ing tomorrow
which is my favorite past
time, Sunday New York Jets,
Buffalo Bills, my official
DailyVee Jets prediction:
Buffalo Bills 16, New York Jets 9
And that is my hope.
I mean I love my Jets.
I know people real fans
don't cheer for losses.
That is just not practical
or strategically correct.
I'm hoping for, in a world
where there's big time
quarterbacks coming into the draft,
I'm hoping for a top
pick, the number one pick.
Lot of music in the air, right?
Just with Dustin; Russ stopped by.
The conversation I just had with Dustin
was an entrepreneurial conversation.
The conversation that
we had with Russ was an
entrepreneurial conversation.
Entrepreneurship is oxygen
across everything,
regardless of what you do,
you need to figure out
how to get people to give a shit about it
and then act on it. And no
matter what you're trying
to achieve, which is bring
awareness to hurricane relief,
or trying to sell your T-shirt brand,
respecting your audience,
bringing them value,
and then delivering on that product.
That's the part that people forget.
That shirt can't be shitty.
Our media services can't
be shitty. That song, songs
can't be shitty. You
can do everything right,
but if the product is shitty you're dead.
And so that is the focus going
in to this weekend for me.
You're consuming this early in the week.
So let that be the rest of your week.
And let's fucking get it.
(music)